[Music]
biden recently published his proposed
budget
six trillion dollars stuffed with higher
spending on an ever more bloated
centralized federal bureaucracy
funded by higher taxes paid by you the
whole point of all this spending they
claim
is to make the economy stronger and more
competitive in the long term they don't
even call it spending it's
investment you see investment so much
better except
it's not so much better in fact it's a
hell of a lot worse because
if you look at the fine print of the
biden budget what they are actually
planning for as the result of all this
investment
is much lower growth 1.8 percent a year
for much of the next decade
back to the stagnation we got under
obama and far below the growth
we saw with president trump with us to
discuss it all is larry kudlow
former national economic council
director of course and host of kudlow
on fox business larry so great to see
you they're not even pretending
this stuff is good for the economy in
the long run
you know that's that's the part i love
about it after you go through this
litany of incredible policies all this
far-left progressive stuff
uh 4 trillion in taxes 6 trillion in
spending
over regulation ending fossil fuels
destroying the energy economy
the green new deal welfare benefits to
illegal immigrants i mean it's kind of
like the policies here
are kind of like bulgaria before the
fall of the soviet union
after you go through all that stuff
steve this is what i love about it
you know at least you'd say well you may
not believe it but we think this is
going to be a workers paradise
and we're going to grow the economy at
four five percent right
that's called marketing let's sell this
thing well
wait a minute if you look under the hood
as you suggested
what are the economic assumptions you
know i wrote three budgets as a kid
under reagan i know who runs the
economic chapter
if you look under the hood it's well
below
two percent so there's no growth
there's no prosperity there's no full
employment
what there is is more what obama used to
call secular stagnation
you know this group does not believe
in growth that is what's clear from this
budget after
all this central planning so-called
transformation
they believe in redistribution
taxing the rich attacking successful
people
and of course everything has a global
warming uh
feel to it and by the way steve if that
all went bad enough hang on one second
this weekend at the g7 finance ministers
treasury secretary janet yellen gave the
worldwide
tax store away total tax surrender
to the eu to the oecd and to the g7
with a so-called 15 minimum global tax
and that will permit european countries
to impose
a digital sales tax on american
companies
this has never happened before this kind
of surrender
to foreign governments and this too this
too
will damage growth and my last point is
real simple
right now if they would just leave this
stuff alone i mean after all
for under two percent why go through all
that rigmarole
we are well in to donald trump's
v-shaped recovery
the economy is roaring it's doing very
well thank you very much
as long as we stop biden policies so
this whole thing this was not invented
by madison avenue geniuses hey
follow us and we're going to get works
i could listen to all night i hope
everyone listens to you
and watches you on on the on the
business job we're so lucky to have you
i just really i'm afraid we're out but
you said it all you said it all but
there's one
one one point i just want to reflect on
listening to you there it's like
as you know originally from the uk
american citizen now very proud american
back in the uk one of the things we used
to admire
about the american political debate or i
suppose the economic debate was
you had both parties at least in america
used to believe in enterprise and growth
and they just sort of argued a little
bit around the edges where in the uk we
had this far left labour party it was
like this existential thing
now here in america it feels like we've
got that they've gone full socialist
and they admit that it doesn't work
that's the hilarious thing about it
larry
so great to see you and as i say
everyone please watch larry's show
on the fox business channel great to see
you tonight thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else